THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
I AGREE ARE CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON THEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LEóN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN [inaudible]
SU CHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
THE FLOOR.
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR SO WE
MAY PROCEED WITH SESSION
MEMBERS
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA RIVER GHOST.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
LIKE PLEASE AT SUCH A PACE
NOWADAYS.
WE LIVING IN THIS AGE OF
SPEEDING TECHNOLOGY.
HAVE OFTEN BECOME MASTERS OF
MULTI TASKING.
DURING THE UPCOMING SPRING
RECESS. TO EASILY WE MIGHT FIND
SOME DAYS QUICKLY FILLED WITH
THINGS TO DO PLACES TO BE IN
PEOPLE TO SEE.
IN THE WEEK AHEAD LET US ALSO
TRIED TO REMAIN AWARE OF THE
AMAZING ACTIVITY OF THE NATURAL
WORLD AROUND US.
THERE ARE MANY WONDERFUL
REMINDERS THAT CAN HELP US
CONNECT AGAIN WITH WHAT IS
REALLY OF VALUE.
YESTERDAY WHILE DRIVING WITH
GREAT PURPOSE TO A FOUR O'CLOCK
APPOINTMENT.
WE HAD TO COME TO A SUDDEN STOP.
WALL A PAIR OF DOCS.
THEY HAVE TAKEN UP RESIDENCE IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD LEISURE THE
WATER CROSS GREEN HAVEN THE
BUSIEST SO STREETS.
HAD WE NOT SEEN THEM THE OTHERS
WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN FLYING.
THEIR OWN HURRIED PACE HAVE PUSH
THE PAUSE BUTTON ON OUR LIVES
AND BROUGHT A SMILE TO OUR FACES
AS WE WATCH THEM SLOWLY CROSS.
WHEN NEXT WE SAW THAT ARE
INNOCENT NEIGHBORS FACE THE
ONSLAUGHT OF CARS QUICKLY
TURNING?
WITH THE GREEN LIGHT FROM THAT
EVEN BUSIER POCKET ROAD.
ANXIOUS I SAID ALOUD.
SLOW DOWN CARS. TO OUR RELIEF.
THE FIRST CAR IN EVERY CAR THAT
FOLLOWS SLOWED TO A CRAWL IN
VERY CAREFULLY DROVE AROUND THE
LEISURELY WATER IN THE IMPAIR.
WE DRIVERS WERE ALL FOCUSED ON
OUR THINGS TO DO PLACES TO BE IN
PEOPLE TO SEE.
BUT WITHOUT EXCEPTION AND
WITHOUT A MOMENT OF THOUGHT.
EVERY DRIVERS REACTION WHAT'S
THE NATURAL RESPONSE.
WE ALL WISH TO NOT BRING HARM TO
THE INNOCENT LIVES TRYING TO
SIMPLY CROSS THE STREET.
IN THAT MOMENT WE ALL FELT OR
NATURAL DEEP UNSPOKEN RESPECT
FOR LIFE.
IF WE LOOK AROUND US EACH DAY.
THERE ARE WONDERFUL REMINDERS TO
HELP US CONNECT AGAIN WITH WHAT
IS REALLY OF VALUE.
WHEN WE CONNECT AGAIN WITH WHAT
IS ESSENTIAL?
WE CAN SENSE AGAIN ARE DEEPER
PURPOSE.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER TO WAKE
AYE KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
BLOOM AS HE LEADS US OF PLEDGE
MISTER BLOW.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
RIGHT ASIAN.
GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. TWENTY TERMS I CRIMINAL
THOSE MARCH FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE THROUGH
ABOUT AND ON THE ON THE ON WILL
COVER MOST REPORTS SOMEBODY SOME
RIVERSIDE SHE FLIRTED US ONCE OF
THE BEST WE COULD ACTUALLY LOSE
READING.
THE ROLES COSTUMER WORKS
MCCORKLE DECENTLY MOTION TO
CARRY TIME OUT THREE TO RETURN
TO RECORD STORES ALARMS MITCHELL
JUROR CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR LACKEY SECOND SAID THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WHAT WOULD YOU MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU? FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC BERMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
[inaudible]
MARC LEVINE
.
MEMBERS WHERE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
BORN A **** BATH AND RAY IS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF ONE OF OUR
BEST GUESS WILL BE SEATED AT HER
DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ. TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
MARK STONE FROM APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL TO
THE SECOND READING. TO SECOND
READING THE BILL IS NO LONGER
FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENTTO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO TO SET BILLS
PENDING REFERRAL. TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO SET A BE
A FIFTY SEVEN DAVID CHIU FOR THE
APRIL FIRST TO APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH HEARING.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
TO SET AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
BONTA. FOR THEIR APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH HEARING PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MINISTRY REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO SET AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE FOR THE
APRIL TWENTY FOUR HEARING.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
TO SET AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WICKS FOR THE APRIL TWENTY FOUR
HEARING PENDING REFERRAL FROM
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO SET A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX NAZARIAN FROM THE
ABLE TWENTY THREE HEARING
PENDING REFERRAL FROM AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE.
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO SET
AB FIFTY TWENTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER FROM THEIR APRIL TWENTY
THREE HEARING PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE MAKE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND TO ALLOW.
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO SET AB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN SAN DIEGO
FOR THEIR ABLE TWENTY FOUR
HEARING PENDING REFERRAL FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCE COMMITTEE.
AND LASTLY TO ALLOW THE REVENUE
TAXES YOU COMMITTEE TO SET AB
TALK TOO SICK TO NINETY SIX
COOLEY FOR THEIR ABLE TWENTY TWO
HEARING.
PENDING REFER RE REFERRAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
TWO I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO PRINT A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
REGARDING AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
BURKE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE MEMBERS WE HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE TODAY
THE HOW SHALL BE IN ORDER.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR REMAINING
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SOON TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE FORTY FIVE LOVE IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSION
COMMITTEE TO ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO KALRA FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO BONTA
FROM THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE MCCARTY
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY LEVINE FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
THE COUNT ABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
GAS.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE.
MS RAY S. FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR HER
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
MS RAY S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IT IS A GREAT HONOR FOR ME TO
INTRODUCE SOMEONE YOU ALL KNOW
ALREADY.
THE LOTUS WHAT THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
YESTERDAY WE CELEBRATED THE
INAUGURAL THE LOTUS WITH THE DAY.
WHICH WAS PASSED BY THIS BODY
AND SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
LAST YEAR.
YESTERDAY WAS HER EIGHTY NINTH
BIRTHDAY.
YET THE LOT IS WHAT THE
CONTINUES TO WORK TIRELESSLY
DEVELOPING LEADERS AND
ADVOCATING FOR THE WORKING POOR.
FOR WOMEN FOR CHILDREN.
SHE IS THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
OF THE LOTUS WHAT THE FOUNDATION.
TRAVELS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
ACROSS THE WORLD ADVOCATING FOR
DEPENDING CIVIL RIGHTS --
CONTINUES TO BE A VOICE FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
THROUGH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
THE LOTUS WHAT THE CONTINUES TO
LECTURE AND TO SPEAK OUT ON A
VARIETY OF SOCIAL ISSUES.
INVOLVING IMMIGRATION INCOME
INEQUALITY AND THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN AND LATINOS.
THE LOTUS WHAT THAT TEACHES THE
CONCEPT OF PERSONAL POWER THAT
NEEDS TO BE COUPLED WITH
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND COOPERATION TO CORRECT
CORRECT TO CREATE THE CHANGES%
NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
THE WORKING POOR.
THE LOT IS WHAT HAS BEEN HONORED
FOR HER WORK AS A FIERCE
ADVOCATE. FOR FARMWORKERS
IMMIGRANTS.
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER FOR THE
WORKING POOR FOR WOMEN FOR THE
LGBT Q..
SHE HAS BEEN IN THE BACK END BUT
A LESS OKAY THIS.
BLESSED AMONG MEN.
OFTEN BEING THE ONLY WOMAN AT
THE NEGOTIATION TABLE.
THE LOTUS HAS BROKEN GLASS
CEILINGS HAS PUSH THE FRONTIERS
OF WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP AND IS
PAVE THE PATH RATHER WOMEN AND
GIRLS. TO FOLLOW IN HER
FOOTSTEPS AND BECOME FUTURE
LEADERS.
WITH THE LOTUS TODAY ARE HER
FAMILY AND ALSO MANY OF THE
STUDENTS THE LOTUS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION.
AND MARTIN LUTHER KING CENTER
FOR TAKING CLASSES ON CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
SINCE WE PASSED TO THE THE LOTUS
WENT THAT DAY.
THE FIRST EVER.
AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING CO
AUTHORS AND JOINT AUTHORS.
SINCE THAT DAY.
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON IN THE
STATE OF NEW MEXICO HAVE ALSO
JOINED AND DECLARED OF THE LOTUS
WENT THAT DAY.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY TO FOLLOW SUIT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE LOTUS
WITH THEM
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
PROCEEDING.
WITH BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE ASSEMBLY SECOND READING.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY ROOM 1-432-439-4657
371-336-1287 TWENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS IN EIGHTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS TO OFFER THE FOR THE
MEMBERS TWELVE SIXTY WITH A
MEMBERS A SIXTY NINE OF THE
MINUTES. FOR FOR THE TO THE
MINUTES NINE TWENTY TWO MM IT'S
NOT A THREE WITH A MEMBERS
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO WITH A MINUTE
SEVEN SIX FOR THE MINUTES. EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT WITH A MINUTES
ELEVEN OH FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
FOUR SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
FOURTEEN NINETY FOR THE MOMENT
SEVEN OH FIVE THE MEMBER
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE MINUTES.
PROBABLY WITH A MINUTE SIXTY
SEVENTY TWO THE MEMBERS SIX
THIRTY SEVEN OF THE MEMBERS
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO THE MINUTES.
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WITH A MINUTES WALK
VERY FOR SEVEN FIFTY FOR THE
MEMBERS EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WITH
THEM IT'S THREE FIFTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WITH A
MEMBERS ELEVEN SIX THROUGH THE
MINISTRY FORTY TWO WITH A MOMENT
SEVEN NINETY TWO WITH A MEMBERS.
EIGHT THIRTY SIX OF THEM IT'S
NINE THIRTY SIX OF THEM IT WAS
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WITH A
MEMBERS FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH A MINUTES 292-622-73390.
443-340-7490 452-553-8613
640-640-5990 810-141-11811.
708-335-44412 FOUR TWENTY TWO
FOUR FIFTY FOUR FIFTY SIX BY
455-656-3690 778-728-05840
589-690-2909 NINE THIRTEEN NINE
SIXTEEN ON 259-407-9732
991-397-1630. THREE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WITH
A MINUTES THIRTEEN NINETY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE WITH A MEMBER IT'S TWELVE
FORTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS A
SIXTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS.
FORTUNATELY WITH A MAN INSTANCE
SIXTY WITH A MEMBERS FOURTEEN
SIXTY WITH A MEMBERS FIFTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN THE MEMBERS FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITH A MINUTES.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE OF THE
MEMBERS FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THE
MOMENT SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO WITH
A MEMBERS FOURTEEN TO THE
SEVERAL DEMERITS. SIXTEEN I WITH
A MEMBERS EIGHT EIGHTY WITH A
MEMBER SIDE A LITTLE THE MEMBERS
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN OF THE MEMBERS
THREE THIRTY WITH A MEMBERS
FORTY NINE WITH MINUTES. FIFTY
NINE WITH A MEMBERS A SIXTY FOUR
WITH A MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVEN FOR THE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU DAVID.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS.
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED
TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE [inaudible]
YOU CAN [inaudible]
PLEASE RISEN.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS ONE OH SIX AND ONE OH
SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN
.
THAT BRINGS US.
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH EIGHT AC ARE THIRTY ONE
BY MS THE MON THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY ONE BY SOME LABOR BELIEVE --
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE MONTH.
MS Là M<c.cyan> YOU MAY OPEN.</c>
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ACR THIRTY ONE DECLARES APRIL
TWENTY NINETEEN AS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MEANT.
BY 202065% OF THE JOBS IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL REQUIRE A
CREDENTIAL OR DEGREE BEYOND HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE AN ESSENTIAL RESOURCE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY HELP THE STATE PREPARE AND
MEET THIS DEMAND.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TRAIN STUDENTS TO BE
COMPETITIVE IN TODAY'S WORKFORCE
AND BRING HIGHER EDUCATION
WITHIN THE REACH OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA VIçT THEY'RE OPEN
ADMISSIONS.
LOW ENROLLMENT FEES FINANCIAL
SYSTEM FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ACADEMIC AND CAREER GUIDANCE AND
TEACHING BY DEDICATED FACULTY.
ACR THIRTY ONE RECOGNIZES THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR MEETING
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC AND CIVIL
CIVIC WELLBEING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AMOUNT.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MS Là M<c.cyan></c>
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MS LIMON IS REQUESTING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R. THIRTY ONE
CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS
.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN
CO AUTHORS AT ON THE RESOLUTION
IT WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MS Là M<c.cyan> YOU</c>
HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
HONORED TO INTRODUCE SPECIAL
GUESTS WE HAVE WITH US TODAY IN
HONOR OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE MONTH.
WE HAVE FAMILY HANES VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE HAVE STEP ON PASSED THE YOUNG
MOST TRUSTEE OF THE SUN FOURTEEN
DELTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
WE HAVE LARRY GALLO EASY
PRESIDENT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ALEXANDER WALKER GRIFFIN STUDENT
MEMBER.
OF THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS FROM
CONTRA COSTA COLLEGE.
AND ALEXIS SAID I GO SAYS
STUDENT MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FROM MODESTO COLLEGE
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
TODAY THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS.
ONE OH NINE THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY FOUR PASS A RETAIN
.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE OUT OF
ONE TWENTY FIVE A. C. R. THIRTY
SIX BY MISTER NAZARIAN CORKERY.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS THERE AND OTHERS RELIGIOUS
PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
MISTER IS THERE AN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
STANTON PRODUCE A C. R..
THIRTY SIX WHICH PROCLAIMS THE
MONTH OF APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS PARKINSON'S DISEASE
AWARENESS MONTH AND URGES ALL
CITIZENS TO SUPPORT THE SEARCH
OF THE RESEARCH TO CURE.
AND TO ASSIST THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO DEAL WITH THIS
DISABLING DISEASE ON A DAILY
BASIS APRIL ELEVENTH IS THE
WORLD PARKINSON'S DISEASE DAY.
ALSO MARKS THE BIRTHDAY OF DR J.
PARKINSON ON THIS DAY THERE ARE
EFFORTS TO MADE TO INCREASE THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS OF THIS
TERRIBLE DISEASE AS WELL AS OF
AS WELL AS ALL THE WORK GOOD
WORK PUT FORWARD.
BY THE WORK BY THE WORLD'S
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED IT TO
ERADICATING THIS DISEASE.
PARKINSON'S IS A CHRONIC
PROGRESSIVE NEUROLOGICAL DISEASE
AND IS THE SECOND MOST COMMON
NEUROGENIC RID OF DISEASE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
U. S. SUFFER FROM PARKINSON'S
DISEASE WITH SEVENTY THOUSAND
NEWLY DIAGNOSED CASES PER YEAR.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS THE
FOURTEENTH LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN THE U. S. AND IS
ESTIMATED TO COST THE COUNTRY.
AT LEAST FOURTEEN POINT FOUR
BILLION ANNUALLY.
AND GROWING.
PARKINSON'S IS AFFECTING BOTH
YOUNG AND OLDER INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIFE EXPECTANCY REDUCED FOR ALL
ON SAID AGES.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS CAUSED BY
BOTH GENETIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS THERE'S NO DIAGNOSTIC
BIOMARKER FOR PARKINSON'S
DISEASE AND THE RATE OF
MISDIAGNOSIS CAN BE HIGH.
THE SYMPTOMS OF PARKINSON'S VERY
FROM PEOPLE A PERSON TO PERSON
AND CAN INCLUDE TREMOR RIGIDITY
SLOWNESS OF MOVEMENT.
DIFFICULTY WITH BALANCE
SWALLOWING CHEWING AND SPEAKING.
COGNITIVE DYSFUNCTION INCLUDING
DEMENTIA DEPRESSION ANXIETY
DISORDER INSOMNIA AND ATTENTION
DIFFICULTIES.
BETTER AWARENESS AND EXPANDED
KNOWLEDGE OF THE REALITIES OF
LIFE WITH PARKINSON'S DISEASE
WILL ALLOW THE CAN COMMUNITY.
AT LARGE TO BETTER SUPPORT
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS DEBILITATING
CONDITION.
THE COMMUNITIES FOCUS ON
PARKINSON'S DISEASE AND ITS
IMPACT ON PATIENTS LIVES WILL
HELP GIVE HOPE FOR A BETTER
FUTURE FOR PEOPLE WITH
PARKINSON'S DISEASE [inaudible]
I AM.
THANK YOU MISTER JERRY MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THAT THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD -- YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
VOTED FOR EVERY YEAR THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE --
BUT THIS THIS YEAR IT TOOK ON A
NEW MEANING FOR ME BECAUSE THE
FAMILY MY A MEMBER OF MY FAMILY
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH PARKINSON'S.
AND SO IT'S IN MY FAMILY IN A IN
A NEW WAY -- AND THE WAY THAT'S
NEVER HIT MY FAMILY BEFORE
BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST PERSON
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED.
WITH THIS NEUROCOGNITIVE DISEASE --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS MORE
ATTENTION ON NOT JUST THIS BUT
ALZHEIMER'S AND EVERY OTHER
NEUROCOGNITIVE -- ISSUE THAT
THAT WE HAVE PLAGUING OUR
SOCIETY RIGHT NOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF OUR FAMILIES
THIS IS SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS
NOT JUST THE LIVES OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TO CONTRACT THIS
TERRIBLE DISEASE.
BUT THE LIVES OF THE FAMILIES
AROUND US WE NEED SUPPORT AROUND
THESE PEOPLE AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND
DESPERATELY DESERVE BUT I I AM
PROUD TO STAND TODAY -- TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND
AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
THIS OVER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION MR NECESSARY YOU MAY
CLOSE WE WISH AND WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU.
TO THE GENTLE PERSON FROM A WIN
HERE MONTEBELLO.
I THINK WE ARE ALL GOING TO BE
EXPERIENCING SOME LEVEL OF NEW A
DEGENERATIVE DISEASE AND OUR
FAMILIES BECAUSE AS THE
POPULATION AGES AND CALIFORNIA'S
AGING REACH. 25% OF THE
POPULATION IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE DEALING
WITH THESE DEBILITATING DISEASES
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND OPEN THE ROLE
ASKED TO OPEN THE RULES FOR
COFFERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEASURES AREA THE
AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE WE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION
.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ARE ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE [inaudible]
JOSE NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN AC ARE. SIXTY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY WITH A MEMBERS BY SOME
REMEMBER THE MR DAVE ON THE MMS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO OFFER THESE
AMENDMENT AND THEY WILL SIMPLY
ADD A JOINT AUTHOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DAVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED.
RESOLUTION IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY NINE AND
ONE THIRTY THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY ONE AB SEVENTY FOUR
BY MR TANG CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN MR TANG
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER
OF MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL
BUDGET BILL AB.
SEVENTY FOUR WE ARE SENDING THIS
BILL AS WELL AS FORTY SEVEN
OTHER BILLS OVER TO THE SENATE --
THE SENATE WILL BE SPENDING
THEIR BUDGET BILLS TO US AND
THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
OF OUR BUDGET PROCESS WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
AND MR A MINORITY ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTY FOUR
COLLEAGUES THERE IS NO NEED TO
SEND FORTY EIGHT COMPLETELY
BLANK BUDGET BILLS OVER TO THE
SENATE.
WE'RE TOLD THIS IS TO START THE
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
PROCESS BUT THERE ARE OTHER MORE
TRANSPARENT WAYS OF DOING THAT
FOR EXAMPLE IF WE MERELY AMENDED
IN THE CURRENT CONTENTS OF OUR
BUDGET INTO THESE BILLS.
THOSE BILLS COULD BE DEBATED IN
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AS EVERY
OTHER BILL IS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR
CONSTITUENTS THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THOSE
BILLS WHICH IS A FORM THEY ARE
DENIED WHEN WE SEND COMPLETELY
BANK BLANK BILLS OVER THE SENATE
I URGE A NO VOTE.
MR MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
PERMISSION IS A PROP.
MISTER CALDERON IS MAKING HIS
WAY OVER TO YOUR DESK MISTER
MATHIS [inaudible]
THAT'S MISTER MATHIS.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A PIECE OF PAPER THANK YOU
MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY A BLANK
PEOPLE.
SERVE PAPER BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE WERE VOTING ON TODAY IN
THE BUDGET.
IS IS BLANK ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
SO I WANTED TO GET A GOOD VISUAL
FOR FOLKS AT HOME.
THAT THIS.
BEAUTIFUL BLANK PIECE OF PAPER
IS THE BUDGET THEY ARE ALL ABOUT
READY TO VOTE ON SO I ASKED FOR
NO VOTE.
LET'S.
LET'S LET'S NOT VOTE ON BLANK
NOTHING THAT'S ACTUALLY VOTE ON
SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE.
ASK FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR PROPS MR TANG YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
THE ANNUAL COMPLAINT WE HEAR
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT BUDGET BILLS.
I JUST A REMINDER I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE ALL THE SUB HERE'S HERE AS
WELL AS ALL THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE.
WE HAVE.
OVER A HUNDRED HEARINGS A YEAR
WITH HOURS AND HOURS OF PUBLIC
HEARING I THINK THE IN
PARTICULAR WHAT YOU TO ONE OF
OUR MùT BROKE MOST ROBUST.
SUBCOMMITTEES WHICH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM TWO AREAS ON IS -- BUDGET
SUB ONE WHERE I BELIEVE THERE
THEY HAVE OFTENTIMES ONE OR TWO
HEARINGS A WEEK -- MANY THE
HEARINGS -- SHORT HEARINGS ABOUT
FOUR HOURS WITH HOURS AND HOURS.
OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY -- AND AGAIN
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THIS IS I A PROCESS THAT HAS
VERY RIGOROUS -- TRANSPARENCY IN
VERY RIGOROUS PUBLIC COMMENT AND
EVERY ASPECT OF THE BUDGET THANK
YOU.
MR MATHIS FOR PURPOSE THE RISER
POINT OF PERSONAL PREFERENCE
[inaudible]
I'D -- VVA CALLED OUT ON BEING
ON MS CALL THEIR ON STAGE FOR
WATER IF YOU HAS THIS POINT OF
ORDER YOU TO SEE THIS POINT OF
ORDER.
STATE YOUR POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER -- PERSONAL PRIVILEGE OF
BEING CALLED OUT FOR BEING A
MEMBER OF A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
WHERE WE HAVE GONE OVER THESE
ITEMS.
AGAIN THESE ITEMS ARE BLANK IN%
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF
US.
SO TO CLARIFY ON TO TO CALL THE
NUMBER OF FOR BEING ON A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON A AND B. OPPOSED TO MISTER
MASSIVE LIKE BUDGET A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE DEALS WITH AN
ATTACK ON A MEMBERS CHARACTER.
INTEGRITY.
NOT NECESSARY RELATED TO A
COMMITTEE POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MISTER TAINT YOU WANT ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR A CLOSE.
THAT'S PROCEED OF A MEMBERS
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT.
I AS FIFTY FOUR NOS THIRTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL VOTE. FOR THE
REMAINING BUDGET ITEMS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION RUN A
SUBSTITUTE THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL VOTE FOR THE REMAINING.
BUDGET ITEMS CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTY FIVE ICE FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SIX I FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME LEGAL SEVENTY
SEVEN EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
EIGHT ICED FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE SEVENTY
NINE EYES FIFTY FOUR DOES
THIRTEEN SO WE WILL.
EIGHTY AS FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME AGO EIGHTY ONE AS
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
AGO EIGHTY TWO I CITY FOR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME AGO EIGHTY THREE
HIGHS FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FOUR EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FIVE EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
THIRTEEN SOME AGO EIGHTY SIX
EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY SEVEN EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
AGO EIGHTY EIGHT ICED FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTY NINE HIGHS FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN SO WE WILL NINETY
ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
SOME PEOPLE NINETY ONE HIGHS.
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
PEOPLE NINETY TWO I CITY FOR
KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME AGO NINETY
THREE II'S FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE SUMMER GOING NINETY
FOUR EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME WE WILL NINETY
FONG EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY
SIX ASK FIFTY FOUR NO SIR. TO
SOME PEOPLE NINETY SEVEN HIGHS
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SO WE
WILL NINETY EIGHT ICED FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME WE WILL
NINETY NINE HIGHS FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTY SO WE WILL. ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THE
ASSEMBLY WILL WANT TO ONE HIGHS
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
PEOPLE WANT.
TO BEFORE KNOWS THIRTEEN SO WE
WILL ONE OF THREE HIGHS FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE
WANT TO FOUR EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS.
SO WE WILL WANT TO FINALIZE
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRD ASSEMBLY
WILL ONE OF SIX FIVE FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN SO WE WILL ONE OH
SEVEN EYES FIFTY FOUR NO SIR TO
SOME WE WILL WANT TO EAT AS
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF NINE I CITY
FOR KNOWS. THIRTEEN SYMBOL ONE
TEN I FIFTY FOUR DOES THIRTEEN
SOMEBODY WILL ONE ELEVEN I CITY
FOR KNOWS THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY ONE
TWELVE HIGHS FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SOME PEOPLE ONE
THIRTEEN AYE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THEIR TO SOME WE WILL ONE
FOURTEEN EYES FIFTY FOUR DOES
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTEEN HIGHS. FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN SO WE WILL ONE SIXTEEN
OZ FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SO
WE WILL ONE SEVENTEEN EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRD SO WE WILL ONE
EIGHTEEN I CITY FOR KNOWS THIRTY
SO WE WILL ONE NINETEEN EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SOME
OF THE ONE TWENTY I CITY. FOR
KNOWS THIRTEEN IN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE TWENTY ONE I STREET BEFORE
KNOWS.
THIRTEEN MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY
[inaudible] TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DELORES
WHERE TO DATE RECEPTION.
UPON ADJOURNMENT.
OF SESSION IN ROOM THREE
SEVENTEEN AND TO LARA SQUARE
TODAY RECEPTION UPON A GERMAN.
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK.
FROM APRIL SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO JANUARY SEVENTH
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
COMMUTER ROUTES PERPETRATED ONE
OF THE GREATEST CRIMES.
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
NEARLY TWO MILLION PEOPLE DIED
UNDER THIS EXTREMIST RULE.
WHICH IMPOSED A RUTHLESS AGENDA
FORCED LABOR.
THOUGHT CONTROL AND MASS
EXECUTION.
UPON CAMBODIANS.
AFTER THE OVERTHROW OF THE
COMMUTER ROUGE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND CAMBODIANS
CAME TO THE UNITED STATES.
AS REFUGEES.
MY COMMUNITY OF LONG BEACH IS
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD IS HOME
TO THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA.
THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE HAVE DRAWN
FROM THEIR CULTURAL HISTORY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND
COMMUNITIES INSIST IN THIS STATE
AND HAVE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY. TO
LONG BEACH AND BEYOND.
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK
WILL HONOR THEIR SURVIVORS AND
THEIR DESCENDANTS FOR THEIR
COURAGE AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE.
AND COUNTRY.
AS WELL AS MY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME AND
RECOGNIZES THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THIS COURAGEOUS AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITY GREAT PEOPLE.
CHINESE YOUNG TANG AUSTIN AIR
GEAR JAKE MERE TODAY WE ARE ALL
CAMBODIAN MISTER SPEAKER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I'LL GO IN TIME.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY WE
COMMEMORATE THE TERRIBLE LOSSES
EXPERIENCED BY ANCIENT CULTURES
IN CAMBODIA.
IN INFLICTED BY THE CAMARO ROUGE
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
I THANK THE MEMBER FROM LONG
BEACH FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
TO US SO THAT THIS SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF HISTORY IS NOT
FORGOTTEN.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE MANY LEFT
CAMBODIA AND SETTLED IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN THE
AUTHORS DISTRICT.
AND IN MINE.
THE IT DOES REFUGEES CAME HERE
HOPING FOR PEACE AND ACCEPTANCE.
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS ASSEMBLY AB
OF THIS ASSEMBLY AND EVERY
AMERICAN SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
THOSE HOPES ARE THINGS TO WHICH
REFUGEES ARE ENTITLED.
THEY NEED THAT PIECE THEY
DESERVE THAT ACCEPTANCE AND WE
CAN PROVIDE IT.
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK
IS A RECOGNITION OF THE TEARS OF
THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE.
BUT IT CAN ALSO BE A CALL TO
REMEMBER THAT OUR COUNTRY IS
NEVER TO FALL FOR REFUGEES.
IN DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHEN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES OFFER
ONLY OPPRESSION?
WE CAN OFFER HOPE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN IN VOTING AYE ON HR.
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
MR HIS AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY EIGHT IN
RECOGNITION OF CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK.
THIS WEEKEND MARKS THE START OF
THE CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR.
THE CULMINATION OF THREE DAYS OF
FESTIVITIES IN WHICH CAMBODIANS
ALL OVER THE WORLD CELEBRATE AND
WELCOME THE NEW YEAR.
IT WAS THE DAY AFTER THIS NEW
YEAR'S CELEBRATION. FORTY FOUR
YEARS AGO THAT POL POT AND THE
CA MY RUCHED.
BEGAN THEIR REGIME IN CAMBODIA
ULTIMATELY MURDERING ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CAMBODIANS BY THE
TIME THE GENOCIDE ENDED FOUR
YEARS LATER.
THE GENOCIDE HAS LEFT A LASTING
IMPACT ON THE REFUGEES FROM
CAMBODIA.
AND THE GENERATIONS THAT HAVE
COME.
AFTER THEM.
AS POLICY LEADERS WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WHO HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY WAR
AND GENOCIDE?
H. R. TWENTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES
THE IMPORTANCE OF COMMEMORATING
THESE HORRIFIC EVENTS SO THAT WE
MAY HONOR THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO
WERE LOST.
AND STAY VIGILANT TO PREVENT THE
STRATEGY IS TRAGEDIES FROM EVER
OCCURRING AGAIN THANK YOU.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TWENTY EIGHT IN THE CITY OF
STOCKTON WE HAVE A LARGE
CAMBODIAN REFUGEE COMMUNITY.
AND ON NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE
ANGRY GUNMEN CAME TO A SCHOOL
THAT HAD A LARGE CONCENTRATION
OF CAMBODIAN REFUGEES.
AND IN THREE MINUTES FIRED OVER
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO ROUNDS
KILLING FIVE CAMBODIAN SCHOOL
CHILDREN AND INJURING.
THIRTY TWO WAS THE FIRST MASS
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND IT WAS.
IT WAS AGAINST.
CAMBODIAN REFUGEES.
I HAVE FRIENDS OF CAMBODIAN
DESCENT WHO HAVE BEEN TALKING
LATELY ABOUT WHAT IT WAS LIKE
WHAT BIRD THEIR MEMORIES OF
THEIR PARENTS CARRYING THEM
HUNDREDS OF MILES. TO GET TO THE
BORDER TO GET TO THE CAMPS TO BE
ABLE TO COME TO THE US.
AND THAT THE THE MEMORIES NOW
ARE RESURFACING WITH THE NEW
TALK THAT WE HAVE THAT'S ANTI
IMMIGRANT ANTI AT REFUGEE.
AND NOT FEELING LIKE THINGS
HAVEN'T CHANGED THAT MUCH WERE
ANGRY PEOPLE STILL SHOW UP AND
BLAME OTHERS FOR THEIR OWN
MISFORTUNE.
SO AS WE VOTE FOR THIS TODAY WE
REMEMBER THE PAST WE REMEMBER
THE THE OPPRESSION THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ENCOUNTERED WE REMEMBER THE
IMPRESSION THAT IS CURRENTLY
GOING ON TODAY.
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT OURSELVES
AND WHO WE ARE AS A COUNTRY THAT
WE THAT WE RE CONFIRM.
AND REAFFIRM THAT WE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WELCOME.
AND THAT WE ARE PEOPLE WHO WITH
OPEN ARTS HEARTS AND OPEN MINDS
SAY THAT WE ARE BIG ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO ABSORB.
THOSE IN PAIN AND THOSE SEEKING
REFUGEE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR RAVEN SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR DONALD YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH SAYS FOR I VOTERS FOR
SPEAKER AND MR O'DONNELL WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION YES.
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR.
TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND BACKIN FILE ORDER MEMBERS
FILE ITEMS.
ONE SEVENTY NINE THROUGH.
ONE NINETY PASS.
AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP.
THE RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
TAKE RUN CALL ONE ROLL CALL VOTE
AND ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTIONS THE CLERK WILL READ
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER FONG
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
CONGENITAL DIAPHRAGMATIC HERNIA
AWARENESS MONTH AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTEEN BY
SEVERAL CHIANG RELATIVES OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND SOME WE THE
CLERK WHEN THE OVER THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A
WHOLE ON TO THOSE.
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
ON THE AFOREMENTIONED
RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT C AUTHORS ADDED THE CLERK
WILL APPLY THAT VOTE TO THE
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON TODAY'S.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
STILL ON CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE OBERNOLTE.
A MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE REST OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING.
NINE THE CLERK READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL A
FIFTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
COOPER AN ACOLYTE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
CLARK WITHOUT OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY LOCAL
CLOSER ALL I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SAN CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ARE CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TO FIFTY FIVE I
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ALSO
LEGAL THREE EIGHTY ONE I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY WITH URGENCY.
I SEVEN WINDOWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE SOME PEOPLE FOR
THIRTY SIX I SEVENTY ONE AS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE FOR
SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE FIND FORTY SIX
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE SIX OH NINE
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX ELEVEN I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME LEGAL SIX NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
NINE OH THREE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE.
TEN ELEVEN I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
THIRTY FOUR I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO CID CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
INCIDENT CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SIX I SEVENTY ONE HE
KNOWS.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS I'M
ORDERING THE DEATHS TO BE HELD
OPEN UNTIL TWELVE NOON ON FRIDAY
APRIL TWELFTH.
THAT IS TOMORROW FOR THE PURPOSE
OF RECEIVING COMMITTEE REPORTS
AND FILE NOTICES THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
APRIL TWELFTH.
THROUGH MONDAY APRIL TWENTY
SECOND SPRING RECESS MONDAY
APRIL TWENTY SECOND FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION A
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
FOLLOWING MEMBER WAS GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK.
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MS
MELENDEZ.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M I
RISE TO DURING TODAY IN THE
MEMORY I'M CHP SURGEON STEVE
LIKE ON HE WAS A RESIDENT OF
PARIS MY CONSTITUENT IN THE
SIXTY SEVEN THE FAMILY DISTRICT.
SERGEANT LIKENS LIFE WAS
TRAGICALLY TAKEN THIS PAST
WEEKEND ON THE EVENING OF APRIL
SIXTH WHILE PERFORMING A ROUTINE
TRAFFIC STOP ALONG INTERSTATE
FIFTEEN UNLIKE ELSINORE.
HE WAS KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER
WAS DRIVING ALONG THE SHOULDER
ATTEMPTING TO GO AROUND TRAFFIC
WE'RE SERGEANT LIKE I WAS
PERFORMING HIS DUTIES.
HE HAD TO BE AIRLIFTED TO A
NEARBY HOSPITAL WHERE HE LATER
SUCCUMBED TO HIS INJURIES AND
PASSED AWAY.
SURGEON LIKE ON WAS BORN ON JULY
FIFTH NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IN
PALM SPRINGS CALIFORNIA THE
OLDEST OF THREE CHILDREN HE WAS
RAISED IN ANAHEIM HILLS IT WAS A
GRADUATE OF CANYON HILLS HIGH
SCHOOL.
HE WAS A TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
VETERAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL WITH TWENTY FOUR
OF THOSE YEARS RIDING A
MOTORCYCLE WHICH WAS HIS PASSION.
HIS RIDERSHIP SKILLS WERE PUT TO
GOOD USE AS PART OF THE C. H.
P.'S PROTECTIVE DETAIL SERVICE
SERVICES DETAIL ESCORTING DICK
DIGNITARIES FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THERE'S DIGNITARIES INCLUDED
PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND I ON THIS
FLOOR WHO RELY ON THE SERVICES
OF C. H. P. WHEN WE ATTEND
ORGANIZE EVENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
STEVE WAS PROMOTED TO SERGEANT
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND AFTER
TEN YEARS OF SERVICE IN THE
BALDWIN PARK AREA HE TRANSFERRED
TO THE RIVERSIDE AREA IN ORDER
TO BE CLOSE TO DO HIS.
HIS HOME AND HIS FAMILY WHOM HE
LOVED VERY MUCH.
STEVE WAS DEDICATED TO HIS
FELLOW PATROLMAN AND LET EFFORTS
TO INCREASE DEPARTMENTS PUBLIC
TRUST BY RESPONDING TO THE NEEDS
OF EACH COMMUNITY SERVED BY THE
RIVERSIDE CHP AREA.
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS REMARKED
HOW MUCH IS PRESENCE IN HIS
JOYFUL SMILE WILL BE MISSED BY
EVERYONE WHO HAS EVER BEEN A
PART OF HIS LIFE.
HE WAS A DEVOTED FAMILY MAN AND
HE LOVED THEM ALL ABOVE ALL ELSE
HE WAS ALSO HAS BEEN OF TWENTY
TWO YEARS.
A LOVING FATHER TWO DAUGHTERS
TWO SONS AND A DOTING
GRANDFATHER.
ON SATURDAY HIS WATCH ENDED HE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY THE
COMMUNITY HE SERVED WITH THAT I
ASK YOU.
TO JOIN ME IN A JOINING I'M IN
THE MEMORY OF STE C. H. P.
SERGEANT STEPHEN LAWRENCE LIKE
KIND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISTER BLOOM
SECOND SET THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
TWENTY SECOND ONE PM WE ARE
ADJOURNED